I need to reiterate that
those were just the basics.
There are a lot of complications
that we're going to address now.
First of all, in the previous example,
we should think about the for loop.
Does the for
the Itself count for something?
In order for the loop to work,
you need to do a computation each time
to get the next letter in the string.
Since this needs to happen one time for
every input letter, we can just add
1 to the value before n, and
now we end up with 3n + 2.
It turns out that it's actually really
hard to predict how many computations
this pseudocode is going to take.
For example,
a lower level language like C would
break down the process a lot more and it
would take a lot more lines of code, but
they would be doing less
work in the background.
The Python version of this might
be about these many lines of code.
But it would be doing a lot more in the
background because it's a higher level
language.
For example, let's look at this line.
This line could take a different
number of computations
based on the data structure
the cipher is using.
Maybe we store data in a list, and
we need to check each letter against
our current letter to solve the code.
That could be as many as 26 checks for
each letter in our input string.
So ultimately our efficiency calculation
might look a little more like this.
Let's go back to those example input
strings we talked about before.
Now if we start out with
a 10 letter input string,
we end up with 292 computations.
If we start out with 1 million
letters in our input string,
we end up with 29 million
steps to go through.
Because of our choice of data structure,
we're doing a lot
more computations than we might if
we chose it a little bit smarter.
Later, we'll talk a little bit more
about the efficiency of different
types of data structures.
But for now hopefully you realize the
importance of thinking about efficiency
before writing code.